In today's world it can feel like
there's no space for silence.
Like we're always required to be
responding to something,
to be saying something new.
Whether that's answering
a text or an email,
a tweet, a WhatsApp message
or even the phone.
My name's Harriet Shawcross.
I'm a film-maker and a journalist
and I think we would all benefit
from a little bit more silence
in our lives.
One of the reasons
I'm interested in silence
and in what can and can't be said
is that when I was a teenager
there was about a year when I didn't
really talk to people at school.
I would answer direct questions
if a teacher asked them
or I would read out loud,
but the kind of communication
that makes us human -
spontaneous conversation,
sharing jokes
was something that
I wasn't able to do.
And it had a huge impact on me
and was really formative
in terms of how I relate to people
both professionally and personally.
So what's so great about silence?
Well in the course
of researching my book
I came across several studies
into the impact
that silence can have
on both the body and the brain.
In one study involving mice,
silence was shown to promote
the growth of brain cells
in the part of the brain responsible
for memory related to the senses.
Scientists played mice
a selection of sounds
including baby mouse cries,
white noise, and silence
and observed that during silence
there was cell growth
in the hippocampus.
Another study looked at the impact
of listening to music on the body
and the researchers found
that if silence was inserted
into a track of music
the blood pressure dropped, the heart
rate reduced and the subject relaxed
much more than when listening
to a relaxing piece of music.
This only happened when the silence
was inserted in the middle
of the tune itself.
It didn't work for silence at the
beginning or end of the experiment.
So there's something about silence
that comes in the middle of noise
that's particularly beneficial.
So silence can actually also
enable people to actually say things
that they've never been able
to say before.
I looked into the formation
of the Samaritans,
a support service for people that
are feeling despairing or suicidal.
The service was set up in the 50s
by a vicar,
and he started it because he had to
conduct the funeral of a young girl
who had taken her own life.
The reason she took her own life
is that she'd started her periods
and thought she'd contracted some
terrible disease and was dying.
She was deeply ashamed
of what was happening to her
and had no one to talk to about it.
It was this that inspired
the vicar, Chad Varah,
to set up the Samaritans
as he didn't want people to feel
that there were things
that they couldn't talk about,
particularly things
that they were ashamed of.
He believed that you should
be able to sit with someone,
no matter what they're going through,
without feeling the need
to answer back or offer solutions
or problem solve.
And a really central way of doing
that is through using silence
and giving them space
to explain what's going on for them.
And frankly,
if normal conversations could involve
a little bit more silence like that
I think the world would be
a much happier place.
So silence is also at the heart
of most major world religions.
In Buddhism silence
is really highly valued
and conversation can be seen
as something that gets in the way
of our experiences.
And if you strip away
all of that language
you're left with a deeper
understanding of your own experiences
in the world and your connection
to other people.
But can too much silence
be a bad thing?
There's a condition known as Assidy
which was experienced by monks
who spent prolonged periods
in silence
and it's basically distinguished
by a feeling of torpor,
of not being able to do anything
and that's specifically associated
with spending long periods of time
without speaking to anybody.
I also spoke to people
who had spent more time
than probably most of us
would want to in silence.
One of them was a Buddhist
who spent nine months
on a silent and solitary retreat
and the silence had
a really profound effect on him.
After a certain amount of time
he felt like he was losing control
of both his mind and his body.
He actually felt
like he was having a heart attack.
He knew logically he'd just
pulled a muscle in his chest
but without anyone to say, "I've
pulled a muscle in my chest" to,
the pain that he was feeling,
the sensations of panic
meant that he actually really thought
that he was dying
and the only way that
he could snap out of that
was by calling a friend of his.
And it was only once he
had words and language
to attach to what was
happening to him
that he was able to make sense of it
and eventually feel better.
So that Buddhist actually described
silence to me as being like love -
it's something that, instinctively,
we all feel we want
and need in our lives
but silence, like love,
is really strong medicine
and it can actually
completely tear you apart.